you know when Donald Trump became the  Republican nominee and eventually  president I insisted I don't believe  Trump has created racism and xenophobia  I think he has coddled it and made the  racists and xenophobes more comfortable  publicly saying the stuff they already  believe similarly Kanye isn't giving  people these ideas these horribly  anti-semitic anti-jewish tropes that  he's been repeating but he is making  people comfortable going out in public  and saying Kanye is right I believe this  stuff look at the comments on my YouTube  channel youtube.com the davidpackman  show on every video I've done about the  Kanye situation and I I was going to say  and you will be appalled you should be  appalled by what there is there